yes rose mcgowan said you know gavin  newsom's wife and their law firm tried  to offer me hush money yeah  and i don't know if it's true or not but  whatever happened to hashtag believe all  women yeah the point is they didn't even  cover it no they're including mcgowan  mcgowan is like the one right yeah they  didn't even cover it but here's what's  important about that they try to say  well really if you think that gavin  newsom is better for women than compared  to i heard them on the radio play a clip  of larry elder saying well you know at  least donald trump has done more for uh  for for uh fat overweight women getting  them off the couch with these marches  than uh any uh michelle obama fitness  initiative has ever that's like they're  like  he hates women so you're comparing a  joke about fat people  to rape